what's the deal with airplane peanuts
so i had to scam at sears the door was
right by the music department
it was right by the door i was parked
right there and just walking
and every day i would take the bruce
springsteen four package collection it
was like the hit of this
it was 99 bucks like 89 bucks for a
bruce springsteen box
he's on the cover with a guitar in his
hand how do i remember
because bruce springsteen put a lot of
money in my pocket
bruce springsteen five at a time and i
would pick him up and walk out there
and i would go right to the hill get my
200 and then
go eat like a [ __ ] sandwich or
something it was destruction
but then i was out on bail on the
kidnapping case
and i was running out of money and i go
you know what i'm going to go back up to
the cd store so i started robbing them
every other day
this went on for about a week or two not
many people can just say that sentence
i started robbing him yeah i was going
to the cd store we had a dad
i didn't want to be a [ __ ] pig no no
regulate yourself
i had to go like every other every two
or three days monday wednesday there was
a student center
i was tormenting them because they would
buy books second hand
and i would just pick up a stack of
books i wouldn't even walk in the front
door i just bring them up and i go my
mother got me these
but i already got them she just wasn't
thinking and they go do you want cash
or check you know what i think i don't
need the cash
but i'll take it and they would give me
back the money for the books plus tax
what's it like to not have a conscience
what's tremendous that's
the greatest life your life is
incredible until you get caught
but then you have the stories what is it
that you want me to do to change that
like that's why it pisses me off that
people go after governors for putting
black face on
or the chief [ __ ] judge because he
covered some chick's mouth in 1982 you
got nowhere to go
so if he would have came out and said
yeah in 1982 i choked the girl at the
party
he would have known he wouldn't have to
deal with that i don't know if it works
in politics the same way
yes it does it does because it works in
life that way if you don't say it if i
get it out first you got no way
that helps that can help you gotta know
where to go right mile when did
when he goes what am i gonna do what are
you gonna do when he goose on you about
the girl
he goes if you put it out there first
he's got nowhere to go right
yeah because the you it diffuses the
situation trump does that a lot you
watch trump he'll be like i did this
and he'll put a little spin on it to
make it my you know his way
it happened there was a lot it was not
my problem and then
people were like yeah yeah he did it so
what it does it's not who i am today
but thinking back at who that person was
that would be out on bail for kidnapping
and would go every other day to either
the student center like one day i went
to the student center i had a watched
rack
with watches timex whatever the [ __ ] i
picked up the whole thing and put it on
my shoulder like a body in vietnam
and i just walked out if you're going to
let me rob and you're not going to pay
attention to me i got to rob you in
those days i was that nuts and bold
yeah that's crazy but you're getting
away with it so why would you stop
getting away i i would control myself
yeah that sounds sound like
that's not controlling yourself what do
you think controlling yourself
is dog i would rob 24 7 if you i
remember when double espresso machines
came out 95 i was a struggling comment
because you're going into stories about
stealing 24 7
and then i remember with double
expressions yeah because i had control
before i got arrested
you get the prison i had i had no
control like that's when i got caught
so i'm out on bail for the kidnapping i
get caught with like 85 [ __ ] cds and
they chase me
like a little black guy in a golf cart
and a little white skinny guy like come
back
and i'm running through and see these
backups and [ __ ] trying to throw them
off like you're a superhero oh my god
they got me the cops finally got me
and i gave him a fake name they arrested
me
and i processed now i just been in there
for a month
waiting to get bail every cop knew joey
i went in there as jimmy
and they're fingerprinting me and i'm
like how are you doing
and i'm looking at the fingerprint card
it's like jimmy whatever
i'm like these guys if you if you're
gonna be that stupid
and then i went back to court as that
guy i was younger and i
did coke oh that was dick for [ __ ]
four hours
yeah you just were giving out dick
they're looking at you like when is this
gonna stop
and then when you do come it's one of
those long loads yeah
you ever have those loads like i used to
i used to be on probation
and there was a dude that was like a gi
joe dude that failed the police test
but his assistant was a good looking
woman like she was kind of cute
if i was 30 she was by 38 nobody talked
to her and boulder because she had like
a wooden leg
like her leg was kind of like she had
like that little limp but you could tell
the [ __ ] had game like she could suck a
[ __ ] i would look at my
eyes and i could tell this [ __ ] is
deadly but nobody talks to her because
of the [ __ ] wooden leg
whatever the [ __ ] she's got she got shot
in vietnam i didn't know what happened i
figured out how to [ __ ] with the piss
test
but with me they had mirrors around me
they couldn't figure out what i was
doing
so they sent her and so before i would
go and i'd [ __ ] do a half a jerk in
the car and get my dick nice and big
yeah and then i'd sprinkle it the
[ __ ] uh pool cleaner pool cleaner
it doesn't sting your deck the pool did
nice i got scars i got little holes in
my dick and
uh drano yeah i would grind it up i
would [ __ ] put it under my dick
and then pull the skin back and it would
fall into the piss test and zap it
but before i would piss i would take the
hammer out and show it though like what
do you think
what do you think there's something nice
and she would look at it and look around
the room
and not like i knew i was going to end
up sleeping with her or swapping spirit
because i flirt with it nobody talked to
the woman because she had a [ __ ] up
leg
so i'm off probation i'm delivering
chinese food and i'm slinging coke at
the same time
at the chinese restaurant so i would
have to i would have you call the
chinese restaurant and say
i talked to joey yeah what's up oh you
wanna drop soup whatever
the cocaine would be hidden under the
egg drop soup so if i got in trouble the
chinese people got in trouble
i didn't put it in the bag this is uh
when i was out already out of prison
one night i knock on the door who
answers the door it's her
and she goes oh my god it's so great to
see you
how have you been like oh it's great to
see you man i gave her a hug
and i put the chinese down and she goes
what are you doing with your life i i'm
getting divorced
but i got into stand-up comedy and i'm
trying to deliver food to make a living
and
she's like oh that's so sweet you and
her broke up oh you must need a hug and
as i started hugging we started swap and
spit
and i touched a little monkey and i
could feel nobody had even touched a
monkey in like 10 years
steam started coming and i started
fingering that [ __ ] like a
savage i put it down
slowly and i pop her pants i take her
out she's got one big [ __ ] damn
[ __ ]
i'm making out with my finger at the
same time
so while i'm fingering i take her pants
down when i go i don't want to see what
the other leg is
so i took the leg off with a good leg
and i left the [ __ ] bad leg coming
because i don't want to know what it is
if she's got like a pole under there one
of those [ __ ] up feet
so i picked up a [ __ ] leg and i
started eating a [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] was huge i'm sucking out like a
peel and
like a piece of bubble come on look up
at it and she's like this christine
with her mouth open i go now is the time
to put the helmet in that [ __ ] mouth
so i switched up i started two-finger
louisiana and i went around
and i put that [ __ ] hammer in her
mouth and she didn't know what to do she
was like
that was and at and that time time
i was trying to [ __ ] lift weights and
[ __ ] so i wasn't jerking off
because somebody told me not to jerk off
that you're protein i was [ __ ] yeah
your humble thought
yeah and when i came in the mouth it was
one of those loads christine that don't
stop you
have one of those things i'd know
because you're sucking it you're sucking
it with your eyes closed
and then after a minute you open it up
because you're like what is this gonna
stop
and i could look at a swallow in it and
it was endless
it was [ __ ] endless it was just a
load of death it was like a month and a
half for not coming there was valium in
there and xanax and [ __ ]
nice seeing you joey thanks for stopping
by
she looked at me she started getting a
little dizzy
i was selling valium at the time i was
taking like 100 milligrams of valium a
night
when i shot in her mouth to put her in a
trance
she was glassy-eyed she gave me a three
dollar tip and i left
and i never saw her again she must have
hate that chinese from the slept for a
week oh my god
oh do you got any dates coming up you
wanna
you could you can still get a twitter
handle you can still feel what that nut
felt like i bet right oh it was like
it was like a three minute nut wait a
minute he didn't even bang her
you don't put it in her vagine no no
that's that's that's the
proceeding was tremendous yeah oh okay
sorry i blacked out at some point i
didn't
listen close once i shove my tongue in
your ass you black out it's like
it's like you're 14 and your uncle's
molesting you you know
he's just black out and what happened
what's gonna happen anyway
as a kid there was a kid in north bergen
i grew up with and he had a name
he was one of those kids that he got
stuck in his mother's [ __ ]
so they had to use one of those forks to
take his head out
the tongue
what was his name vinnie warhead they
used to call him
so they called him vinnie roy on the
street he was a little bit of a tart but
he was okay he had a little jewel to him
and [ __ ]
so he wanted to be a fireman that was
just yeah i won't be a fireman
i won't be fired fireman so they
wouldn't make him a via fireman so they
might have a volunteer fighter
but they gave him like a shield just to
like appease him
they gave him like that no that wouldn't
fit with the helmet
that was the problem they had to give
him like a halloween
like a witch's head so he could if he
got hit in the head with a brick
it would hurt him so he sued the town of
north bergen because they wouldn't make
him he got his [ __ ] diploma
but he sued to tell him because they
wouldn't make him a fireman
because they couldn't find a helmet to
fit his head so vinnie warhead
said [ __ ] it they gave a little money to
go away
they paid them off they paid them they
gave him the michael jackson
they gave him the bike they gave him
like 25k to get to get a bicycle and a
dog
okay i swear to my mother's grave that's
all it takes to give up your dreams so
he was a volunteer fireman
they thought he would forget all about
it right right he was showing up at the
fire
so about a month he wasn't even going in
on the on the trucks
he would just show up with like a truck
with lights on it and [ __ ]
and then after a year after a year
he started lighting his own fires uh-huh
just to put him out just have something
to do
no and he would call the fire department
and before they get there he come out
running through the trees
and he should be a fireman with his
little witch hat on
he'd be yelling with his little witch
head on i'm a better fireman than you
guys
i got here before you and i don't even
have a house in a ladder with a speaker
dog i think he killed himself they
[ __ ] arrested him as [ __ ]
and poor little vinny war had iced
himself i think i don't know
this is united no lax to newark
i'm sitting there the plane lands
the plane's about to land and i take my
phone up
and i turn the phone on and the guy in
the window seat
says i look at him he goes
turn the sun off
a german guy there's two german guys
sitting next to me
they were [ __ ] whatever they talk
nazi hate you know jew haters whatever
the [ __ ] they are uh-huh
and they're both sitting there [ __ ]
hocking each other that that [ __ ]
hero and whatever the [ __ ] they do with
their hands and [ __ ]
so finally can you believe this he goes
not even excuse me yeah sir you might
get in trouble he goes
turn the phone off
and i go what and he goes turn the phone
off and the guy in the middle goes did
you not hear him turn the phone off i go
bro who the [ __ ] do you think you're
talking to
i go don't ever [ __ ] tell me to do
anything go [ __ ] you and [ __ ] him
and they're both gonna wait till we get
off the plane we'll see i go well we'll
[ __ ] see
and the store is there a problem and i
go this [ __ ] hump
tried to tell me to turn the [ __ ]
phone off and she said control your
language and all this i'm like no
i'm not controlling my language don't
ever [ __ ] tell somebody
don't you ask them and the guy kept
talking
and finally i go what if i got up and
just kicked you against that [ __ ]
door
right now because you're in the last
seat i wouldn't be saying a word if i
was you
because if i start swinging i could be a
[ __ ] madman
why are you talking if you're in the
third seat in the [ __ ] aisle
all i see was holding your hands up and
me stomping on you that's all i see
you got a no-win situation you could be
johnny mma
i get the first drop on you that that
leg weighs 265.
once it goes into you i'm going to keep
putting my leg into and kicking you
and your [ __ ] hitler buddy here so
the [ __ ] stewardess kind of
separates us because i told him how long
ago was this
this had to be last week now around that
time this was like an incident okay
i kept having the sopranos was hotter
than hell yeah at that time
so i was having different [ __ ]
incidents every other [ __ ] week
some of them were good some of them were
people busting my balls about the
soprano that you were the guy
it was just like an ongoing so now they
separate us on the plane
because i told the guy what if i started
kicking you right now what are you gonna
do
are you retar you can't be that [ __ ]
stupid talking all that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] third seat
i wouldn't say a word i'd wait till i
get in the hallway where i got an even
chance but that's how stupid you are
so the the stewardess comes over
she gets me up and sure enough you got
to sit here until the police have been
notified
what god damn it so now
i'm aggravated because my friend in
those days we had no dough
you got to have your friends circle like
a [ __ ] struts around the airport
so i'm like you know my friend's waiting
for me to go you're the last guy to
board
you on boarding with the pilot so we get
up
and i forgot i'm in new jersey
so as soon as i see the cops all i have
to do is get them first
all i got to do is get to that cop first
and let him hear me
so that's exactly what i did i went
right up to the cop and i go this
[ __ ] guy
the cop's like what's going what's your
problem here this [ __ ] guy tried to
tell me they're turning the phone off
and then i started with this [ __ ]
white [ __ ] well we the phone is not
supposed to be turned on like shut up
i'm like first of all you're the [ __ ]
away team [ __ ]
once i said that it was on i go you're
the away team you got no say in this
this is jersey
you don't tell somebody from jersey to
turn the [ __ ] phone i'll [ __ ] this
guy
[ __ ] him don't ever [ __ ] talk to
somebody like that and the cops are like
he's got you there yeah
so the one cop walked them and the one
cop walked with me and i just kept
saying [ __ ]
let me get away [ __ ] don't ever
forget that [ __ ]
we got you
you